[Music]
we're obviously playing pretty
aggressively so let's play e4
all right and that's already stumped him
okay this is interesting
i don't know if he's planning to make a
move at some point today or he's doing
his own speed run
e6 there we go
okay so the french now
there's many many lines against the
french that are perfectly viable
and um you know they
most of them start with d4 there are
alternatives to d4
uh and there's a couple of sidelines
here which are very interesting even the
move queen e2
is quite interesting the sideline
to the french that is perhaps the most
interesting at this level is the king's
indian attack
the king's indian attack against the
french i would say for this rating range
if you fear the french
and you've never found anything good
against it king's indian attack can
solve a lot of your problems
so the concept behind the king's indian
attack
is that you literally put on essentially
a king's indian setup with white
but the movie six is a pretty big
concession in those kinds of structure
so it's not like a kings indian
it's its own opening so you play the
move d3 that's how it starts
it looks incredibly lame like why would
you play d3 when you can play d4
well obviously the point is that you've
built up built up your own pawn chain
and how does white continue what is the
setup what's the next move
now black threatens to take on e4 and
force a transition to an end game we
don't want that
so we don't want to play g3 immediately
that's wrong if we play g3
first black takes on e4 we take back
we allow a queen trade and white's king
has to take that's always very awkward
it's also not knight c3 it is knight to
d2
knight to d2 is the king's indian attack
move
and now we go knight gf3 and then g3
so now we can play g3 immediately it
doesn't really matter
it's a little bit more flexible to play
knight gf3 first nights before bishops
i'll talk a little bit afterward about
why we want the knight on d2 because
i totally understand why you would look
at this and say doesn't it block the
bishop
yeah and literally as i was saying that
i think people are typing this in the
chat
so there are very specific reasons
behind this and they're not too hard to
understand
but to understand them you need to also
understand the main
follow-up setup so let's see if we get a
chance to to display that
now we go g3 bishop b2 is also possible
that's that's its own setup
that's called a han m setup and it's
quite passive i've never liked it
we encountered the bishop we castle
so simple chess and yeah and he's given
us a chance
to showcase the way in which we
generally unfurl our pieces
now this is a setup or a scheme which if
you don't know
it becomes very very difficult to
justify
playing the king's indian attack against
bridge you need to know this sequence of
moves
and the purpose behind the sequence is
to develop an attack against black's
king
so this is deceptively it sort of looks
passive it looks very modest
but the king's indian attack can morph
into a very aggressive
setup and a lot of very beautiful games
have been played in particular bobby
fischer played a classic game
uh in in a olympiad in the 60s which
perhaps some of you may have seen
that was a king's indian attack against
the french i think
so the first thing that we need to do
is we need to close down the center so
we go e5 attacking the knight closing
down the center
beethoven dog is thankful for the prime
the second thing
is to solve the problem of this bishop
being blocked by the knight
so perhaps you're thinking along the
lines of going knight b3
but the knight's not going to be doing
anything on b3 it's going to be just
sitting on the queen side with no
prospects
we need to find a way to route the
knight somehow to the king side
and it may appear that there aren't any
good squares
who can tell me how this problem can be
resolved
yeah rookie won that f1 after rookie won
that f1
we can get this bishop to f4 and where
is that knight going to go from f1
that's where the other component of the
setup comes in and i'll
i'll spell this all out after the game
so it won't be quite
as overwhelming you play h4
and then that knight through f1 goes to
h2
and then to g4 and from g4
you are already ready to sacrifice for
example on h6
but when you have a scheme when you have
a system of moves it is extremely
important
to not just automatically execute the
moves but to figure out in what order
they should be played so here
if you look at this knight where can it
go well it can go out to g5
so it makes sense for us to modify
slightly the order of
of moves and play what first what should
we start with here
given this very strange move knight h7
of course we should start with this move
to restrict the knight
that's part of the reason again not to
keep harping on the london system
but when you play an automatic sequence
of moves
you often lose the nuance of why one
move should be played before another so
if you do play
one of these schematic openings make
sure that you're always asking yourself
well maybe in this position i need to
interchange the move order
because of a particular circumstance now
we got ricky one
so f5 is good that's uh i like that move
black tries to close down the king side
and of course we can't afford to let it
close
we have to take on passant here most you
know 80 percent of times
you take on poisson against f5 and you
take the pawn against f6
in order to keep things open now this
square is kind of weak
this knight is really out of play and
now we just continue
along the lines that i've illustrated
which is of course the move knight f1
this looks very very passive it still
doesn't you know if you don't play the
king's indian attack i expect that this
will look
quite lame actually but if you give it a
chance
it'll unfurl and hopefully you'll see
why it can be very very good
now clearly we have a pretty much a
different type of position here than i
had intended
so we need to modify our play
accordingly
and when you play c5 it signals to me
that this pawn on d5 has become a little
bit loose
so what move comes to mind again how can
we modify our development
to take into consideration and to
exploit the weakness of the d5 pawn
we can go knight e3 again it blocks the
bishop a little bit
but the bishop does have d2 it's not
like every piece has to be developed
to an incredibly active square the
knights and the light squared bishop are
going to be doing
the heavy lifting here this bishop can
chill out for a little while
d4 what should we meet this with well
thinking about the squares that this
weakens
we can stick the knight on this very
nice c4 square this is a classic idea
that you see in the king's indian
and he's playing quite well bishop g4 is
good
now we have a pin we want to deal with
this pin
particularly because the f file is open
i don't want this knight to be under a
lot of fire
so to deal with the spin we can't play
h3 we've already played h4
we have a couple of very interesting
moves here
um but i think we have quite a sexy way
of attacking this bishop
if you think inventively if you're
creative
rook to e4 sticking the rook on the
other weak square
created by the move d4 and it might be
paving the way for an exchange sacrifice
if he goes h5 we are going to
do our first positional exchange
sacrifice i'm really
hoping that he goes h5 which is a super
tempting move solidifying his bishop
on the outpost he goes rook uh queen to
d7 instead
and that's a tactical blunder that's a
that's a pretty high level tactical
mistake
now the first thing that i see when you
place queen d7 is
remember the fact that the queen is the
worst defender queens are very bad at
defending minor pieces because they're
so susceptible to attack
and if you're very careful if you look
carefully at
what the other drawback is well the
queen is lining itself up
right into the line of fire of white's
knights
so i'll spare you the calculation if
i've calculated it correctly this move
just is possible
and we've had these tactics before a
million times where we're attacking
black's queen
if he takes our queen we take his if he
takes our knight
then we take this bishop on g4 it's not
terribly
unusual to have this kind of tactic he
does take the queen we take his queen
attacking simultaneously his rook and
also his pawn on c5 so
his position begins to fall apart now
what should we take
should we take his pawn or should we
take his
bishop bit of a tricky question
i have a feeling a lot of people are
tempted to take his bishop just because
but no if we take his bishop he takes
with his knight his knight reemerges
from the dead
our rook hangs and remember his bishop
attacks c2
so it's important to take c5 so that if
he takes c2 which i think he will
he will not be then attacking also the
pawn on d3 we have a
a moment to catch our breath to smoke
this bishop out of c2
which we can do by dropping the rook
back to e2
and now we open up a quite a devastating
attack on bc okay so he goes b6
now order of operations is kind of
important here
um rook takes c2 is a very tempting way
to start
but after rook takes c2 we give him an
additional option
believe it or not rook takes c2 is
inaccurate because if you think for a
second does he have to play b takes d5
did you check for intermediate moves
no after rook takes c2
he has one move i want somebody to find
this move
if you first take his bishop he plays
rook a to c8 and amazingly
the knight is pinned white is still
completely winning there
and i'll show you the best course of
action after the game in case you had
fallen for that
but this can be entirely obviated if you
just take the rook first
no matter what he takes he takes either
the bishop or he takes the knight we
simply take his bishop
and it's over he can try bishop d1
intermediate move we just drop the rook
to e1
he's going to end up down in exchange
for no compensation and a pawn
i hope the tactics make sense there i'll
spell them out in more depth afterward
he takes this way which is not the best
option because he drops another pawn and
now it's just
very very easy technical task finally
we have a chance to develop our bishop
but if we really wanted to be pedantic
about this
what move would we play before bringing
out our bishop if we really wanted to be
as precise as possible we don't want to
allow his rook
to access either of these squares so we
would go king f1 first
yeah nice nicely done and then we would
play bishop d2 and rookie one and all
that jazz
okay so he attacks dax the rook rook can
go to e5 we can go to
let's go rook c7 bring it to the seventh
rank
rook a5 is fine yeah we there's no
reason not to snag another pawn
just you know connected passers as long
as we
are sure that we develop our bishop yeah
so
now has now is the time to develop your
bishop if you just
fall asleep and start pushing your pawns
you allow a check on e1 there's no need
for that
we have a perfectly good square here on
f4 all right so he's just starting to
give up all his pawns etc that's why we
play h4 by the way one of the reasons
not only do did we open up a pathway for
the knight but we prevent g5
okay we can take another one
and we'll stick the knight now there are
two ways of winning the game
the first thing that i see we can simply
push this pawn it's not very efficient
but
it's very very simple the second is to
basically go for checkmate
to go for checkmate you'll need to
preserve this h6 pawn how do we preserve
that pawn
there's a quite a nifty quite a nifty
little maneuver here
that starts with king g2 in order to
activate the rook and bring it to h1
yeah that's just something you kind of
recognized as a pattern
and i wouldn't go h7 here because of the
possibility that it causes stalemate
believe it or not so you have to be a
little bit careful here
i would well you can do a bunch of
different things i would go
something like rook h4 not to be labor
the point here
i'm trying to find a way to deliver
checkmate it's not that easy though
as i realize now so one thing we could
do here is we could cut off the bishop
with a move
f4
and then at the right moment we're going
to go h7 but only when the moment is
right
so the moment is not right yet let's go
rook g4 threatening the rook trade
okay and now you know what in the
interest of simplicity
who can tell me how we can force the
rook trade this is
not the best technique ever but
how can we what how can we trade rooks
we can go h7
now it's scary to stalemate the king but
remember he has a dark squared bishop
our king is on the light square
he has no way to give up his bishop by
force so
there's literally oh god i'm sorry to
hear that there's
literally no way for him to give up his
bishop but this is only something you
should do if you're very confident
right when you're stalemating your
opponent's king you have to make sure
that there is no way that he can give up
his pieces by force resigns okay we
didn't check maybe black but this is
good enough
okay we'll take a look at fisher's game
first
as a way of introducing you to the
king's indian attack and then it'll be
easier
for you to understand my moves in in
that context so we're going to make a
little bit of a detour
um this is a very famous game
between fisher and mia mercer as a
mongolian player he's an im
still alive this was in the end arizona
in tunisia
and um bobby was very much ahead of his
time he played openings that weren't
very popular in his day
and he understood them very very well so
you can see here
uh very familiar setup knight d2 bobby
plays g3 first it doesn't really matter
but just to to recap um
if you go g3 first you allow the option
of trading queens which is not something
you white necessarily wants to allow
uh and the second question is why
knight d2 versus knight c3 and
i think the simplest reason is that
after knight c3 knight f6 you're up
against the same problem
as before which is that if you play g3
black can play d takes c4 that's the
simplest move and once again you have to
force
uh to go into an end game which you
don't want to go into
so it's just knight d2 is the only way
to make this kind of setup work and also
if you think about the long term this is
precisely the knight that often
contributes the most to an attack
against black's king
it's crazy to talk about an attack
against black's king but in the main
line that's exactly what white's aiming
for
no you want black to play well no knight
c3 d4 is not scary
because to a king's indian player
closing down the center is rarely a
scary prospect
that's this is actually what you would
want black to play
because with the center closed your
hands are untied
for king side action blah blah blah so
this is not scary
uh but what's scary is the sort of
specific difficulty that white has in
preventing d takes e4
okay so knight d2 knight f6
now fischer's opponent plays the main
line c5 knight c6 very natural play
black kind of plays as if he was
white and the king's indian so you get
those vibes in fact
if black spawn were repositioned to e5
here you would literally have the main
line of the king's indian the old main
line with knight bd2
or knight b87 with carlos reversed it is
precisely the fact that black
does not have time to play five which
makes this
a very dangerous setup for white because
it is
white who now goes e5 as i did in the
game
so e5 knight d7 and rookie one
and this game is famous because bobby
shows in
sort of very vivid detail uh and in sort
of textbook fashion
how white is able to unfurl his pieces
and create
massive attacking chances so
how does this work well black starts
an attack against the queen side b5 just
like in the king's indian
white plays the moon knight f1 bobby
plays knight f1
b4 nowadays i think a5
is considered to be the main move sorry
not a6 but a5 is considered to be
the best move and black generally pushes
the a pawn forward first
i won't delve into like all of the
technical detail
blah because h4 and bishop f4
yeah so h4 suits uh serves a dual
purpose
the first is that it prevents g5 it
might seem bizarre
well is g5 really a threat it actually
is why goes bishop f4 immediately i
believe the g5 is very very strong
you don't have that many good squares
and after g4 the knight is essentially
stranded
there's no good squares either you have
to play this incredibly awkward move
and black can either take e5 or take the
knight on h4 and then upon an h4
so it literally does prevent g5 in the
first place and in the second place
it creates this h2 square which could
serve as the transit point for either of
the knights
and you often see the maneuver that i
described knight h2 knight g4 although
that i can reach that square via e3 as
bobby didn't in this game
or in some situations this other knight
can move to h2 and let the queen and
that's what i call
opening the gate there's no other way to
do that
i hope that makes sense and of course
finally this pawn itself could be
then used as a battering ram and you
could just you know do the normal stuff
with h5h6
okay so a5 bishop f4 a4 black tries to
do what he can to attack on the queen's
head bobby plays a3 that's a nice move
um it's a nice prophylactic move because
if fischer just goes knight e3 or knight
h2 immediately
he was worried i think about creating
this like swiss cheese complex on the
queen side
so this is something you will see a lot
in games of the legends is that they
will be attacking
then they'll take one or two very well
timed tempe
and slow down their opponent's attack
which is an incredibly annoying thing to
face
okay so b takes a3 b takes a3
and black continues to do what he can
to try to get stuff going on the queen
side but knight a5 is a bad move
this was not very well known at the time
this game was played so
fischer's opponent while a very strong
player was sort of at sea here's
you know stranded at sea and he didn't
know
the sort of typical ideas here i don't
actually know what the correct
way of playing here for black is but
like i said i'm pretty sure
b4 is already an inaccuracy anyways at
a5
fischer plays knight e3 just as we
discussed
uh bishop a6 and now bobby plays the
move which i didn't mention
bishop h3 again not a movie you see
every day in the king's indian
what's the purpose of this move if you
look at it you might say well
isn't he sort of biting on granite right
bishop just stares at the e6 pawn which
is perfectly well defended but there's a
very tactical idea that stands behind
this
if you give white another two moves you
could go
knight g5 and already in this position
you guys should be seeing what this
leads up to
you can see that the sacrifice on e6
either with the knight or the bishop
can potentially be incredibly strong it
causes black's entire pawn
center to capsize and queen h5 is strong
as well
so that's a sort of a secondary idea
black plays d4 tries to prevent this
from happening now bobby plays a very
constructive move why not bishop first
yeah bishop first is also possible
either move bishop b6 or 96 depending on
the situation
uh remember that you're not really going
for material here you're going for
essentially going for checkmate so
i think the tempting move is to play
knight g4 but
it's tempting only because it is the
only non-retreating move that's possible
but it's counterproductive
given the last move because it blocks
the bishop's diagonal
and it also blocks the queen's passage
to h5
you don't want this knight on e3 to have
anything to do
with the attack so far so bobby simply
drops it back to f1
just knight f1 and if you think about it
this knight
can later reroute from d2 to e4 the
position is closed
so quite often you do have the time to
sort of go back and forth and reroute
this way in that way
yeah but knight g2 where would you go
from there like knight g2 seems to have
less prospects
than the knight on f1 at least to me
although it's probably fine as well
okay black goes knight b6 he tries to
get his own knight onto an outpost
and bobby goes knight g5 black goes
knight d5
and of course at this point it would be
extremely premature
to take on e6 it doesn't do much bishop
b6 king h a congratulations no follow-up
and um yeah that was that's interesting
demon
that's probably an alternative and
bishop takes c6
is just not very impressive either fv6
knight e6
again this is not in the spirit of the
position you've given up all of your
attacking pieces
you've given up your fiance bishop
white's king is just toast here and look
at all these squares
look at this diagonal so this is
unthinkable
you've got to be very very careful about
giving up two pieces for rook and two
ponds
it can be easy to fall in love with the
rook and two pawns but in a middle game
you have to make sure that you're not
giving a minor piece that's
very important to for example the safety
of your king if that makes sense
um can you go with the idea that i
talked about well
at this point fischer is uh in a bit of
a
you know in a bit of a tight spot
because black does want to take on f4
eliminating
the dark squared bishop and ruining the
integrity of white's pawn structure
which is very important
so for instance if you were to go 92
here and say well that's no big deal i
can just take with a pawn
what's the big deal well this is kind of
a big deal h6
you you got to move the knight and you
know this one hangs
again like white's structure starts to
collapse the king is weak
why allow this like this is just a
little bit annoying and bobby goes
bishop d2 again
a kind of move which some people would
hesitate to play because it's a
retreating move
but fisher understands that he's got all
of the ingredients in place
for a devastating king side attack he's
absolutely not shy about
doing what he can to preserve all of the
pieces
bishop takes g5 i think this is another
mistake
black doesn't realize the long-term
consequences of giving up his dark
square bishop are severe
and you will see why they are severe in
just a second but of course
fischer wanted to go queen h5 and at
this point sacrifices on e6
were a little bit more on the table uh
but nonetheless i think uh
that was not the most resilient move for
sure
okay um so bishop takes g5 of course
fisher takes to the bishop
and queen d7 and fischer according to
uh the plan that we had discussed ghost
queen h5 anyway
while this does not threaten mate it
brings the queen into the game
and g6 would create once again the sort
of swiss cheese complex he would go
queen h6 so the lobster pins are made on
f6
so black is nothing better than to try
to continue
attacking on the queen side and now
comes
perhaps the most important moment in the
game
it's not so easy to come up with a way
to continue the attack but this is where
the genius of fischer's knight retreat
to f1 comes in
now is the time to involve the knight
knight d2
you want to go knight e4 and then either
knight d6 or even knight f6
creating devastating weaknesses on
black's king's side look at how
patiently he's attacking
black goes knight c3 that's a good try
he's trying to prevent him or discourage
him from going to e4
but fischer immediately realized that
this paves the way
for the game-winning tactical sequence
um which is that the knight
leaves d5 one of the things the knight
was doing there
is controlling the f6 square now a very
typical tactical idea
i'm sure that you've kind of seen this
uh this pattern before bishop f6
it's not so surprising black's king is
all alone
this is the typical sacrifice to you
know to
to try to get a lobster pincer mate
black doesn't take he goes queenie 80.
he tries to get his queen
out of desperation to f8 fisher goes 94.
and you know had he taken the bishop
after he takes f6
this threat of queen g5 and queen h6
leads to a quick mate
i suppose black can go king h8 here and
now let me try to find
the fastest path to check me one moment
yeah here i think
okay who can come up with an idea here i
think i i think i know what fisher's
idea was
it's quite a nice move you need another
piece on the king's side you just need
one more piece
to cooperate with the queen and what's
the piece that cooperates best with the
queen it's the knight
well where would you lift the rook
queen h6 rook g rookie five wrote g6
but knight e4 knight takes e4 where are
you going with the rook it's
way too slow the move is knight f3
and uh that's a very deep move because
you're threatening both
knight e5 and knight g5 and after rook
g8
you don't go knight g5 allowing rook to
h5 you go knight e5
forking the queen on f7 the queen and
the knight are the best tandem in chess
so it's it's important to recognize that
when you're searching for the move
okay so fischer's opponent goes queen
eight
fischer goes knight e4 and this is a
dual purpose move you want to go knight
g5
but if knight takes c4 then this paves
the way for a rook lift that's going to
be
clearly devastating g6 future goes queen
g5 nice move
resisting the temptation to go queen h6
that would have been counterproductive
due to queen fa but now the weaknesses
have been created
deadly weaknesses along the dark squares
all that remains
is a very very simple attacking
operation to open up black's king
just a little bit more how do you do
that you go h5
it's how bobby plays the biggest like in
your face move
ever c takes d3 would be an automatic
reaction but he realizes that he doesn't
have to do anything you can just totally
ignore
everything that black is doing on the
king side and just go rook h4
he understands that the h file is about
to open and he puts the rook there
in advance of that rook a7
now fischer plays a move here there's
many ways to win
fischer plays a move that would become
very very famous bishop to g2
this is a completely enigmatic move it's
entirely unclear where he's going with
the bishop why is he wasting time on
this move
and you're going to see why in just a
second d takes c2
bobby plays queen h6 after queen f8
a very famous move you guys are already
indicating uh this move this is again
the end of this game is very very
classic
and this also shows why he put the
bishop on g2 i love these kinds of moves
that set up a combination like three
four moves later
and then move of course is queen h7 h
takes g6
if king g8 then rocket shade is made and
if king takes g6
finally the move bishop g2 becomes clear
bishop b4 is checkmate
yeah this is very pretty all the pieces
cooperate
um and what i love about this game is
how fisher went bishop h3
in order to pressure e6 and then brought
it back to g2 when it was necessary to
do that
yeah just a phenomenal game and of
course one could argue that black was
not
particularly um you know
how should i put it black's attacking
attempts on the queen side were not very
sophisticated he let fisher get all he
wanted
nonetheless the uh this game illustrates
i think very well
the uh main attacking ideas in the
king's indian attack
okay um now obviously this
this uh gave rise to 50 years of
king's indian attack theory nowadays um
the king's indian attack against the
french is very well studied
black has a million viable setups that
all
equalize and get different types of
positions so you don't play the kings
indian attack
to get an advantage out of the opening
you play it to get a fresh position
and to practice certain types of
positions and sometimes to get very nice
attacks
okay transitioning back to our game
hopefully it'll be a little bit easier
to understand some of the ideas
through the lens of fisher's game
and sorry if i went a little bit too
fast at various points i hope
people were able to follow the general
arc of the game
all right i played the king's indian
attacks the french
quite a few times with a lot of success
these ideas are valuable for the kings
indian with one caveat
white does against the king's indian
i've had this against min for example a
million times
sometimes but not very commonly white
will put his pawn on e3 and do something
like this
and you literally could get a reverse
king's indian attack
um so i've i've definitely faced this
system before and
with a tempo down but still the same
type of position you get
yeah so it is valuable okay
so e46 blah blah c5 is fine bishop b7 is
a bit of a weird way
to start the development although
there's nothing wrong with that
if white goes or flacco's knight c6 or
castles he
continues along the main line he goes h6
which is a bit of a waste of time
um it's quite a passive move we're not
trying to put our bishop on g5
and that does create a long-term hook
which we can use to sacrifice on later
castles castles and e5
and knight h7 is where black really
substantively deviates from
from the fischer game and from the main
line if black had played knight fd7 we
would have played exactly as fisher did
rookie 1 and f1 h4
and the presence of the pawn on h6 only
acts in our favor
because we can sacrifice on that square
later
okay knight h7 we start with the move h4
in order to keep this knight in exile
not allow it to go to g5
knight c6 rookie one and
f5 is interesting this is something that
fisher's opponent could have played
but it's generally not a particularly
good idea it ensures the black's not
going to get mated
uh and the reason that is is because if
we just blindly going at f1 you're going
to find that you just don't have any
real estate
remaining on the king side right when
the pawn is on f7 you have all this
space to maneuver but then
now the snipe doesn't have the
possibility of going to g4
so you're operating under a cloud and
there's just nothing that y can do here
so it is very important here to take on
passant
open up the position give the rook
control over the e file the e5 square is
weak
and we can continue uh along the same
line
knight f1 all right um
so e5 is very natural if he doesn't play
e5 our plan will revolve around
seizing control of the e5 square
for example if black plays bishop d7 we
can go knight h2 knight e3 doesn't
really matter
i would go 93 and
then we go knight g4 and positionally
white is already dominating
because we've got this bind on e5 we can
go bishop f4
then eventually we can go knight e5 uh
and and we've just got a great position
there's a backward pawn on e6
look at how all of our pieces now have a
tremendous degree of activity
so e5 from that perspective makes sense
but it does weaken the d5 score which we
immediately try to exploit
now d4 i think is a mistake i think
there was no need
to weaken these squares and to allow the
knight such a beautiful square on c4
what would you offer instead for black
what seems to be a more level-headed
move
and by the way e4 is nothing to fear
because after ded and 92 the pawn cannot
be defended this is
very bad as well so you shouldn't push
any pawns here you should complete your
development
with what move thank you
sean roberts bishop e6 is correct
and what should white do here what is a
couple of approaches
bishop g4 blunders the bishop by the way
but my favorite approach is to drop the
other knight to h2
extending the pressure on d5 and then
reroute that knight over to g4 in order
to maximally increase the pressure on
black's position
you also can send the queen over to h5
although i like that less
because you're not really trying to
check mate black here that makes sense
um you just have very big pressure on
black center this is
not the kind of position everybody wants
to get with white you have to be okay
with your opponent having a big center
but if you are okay with that then you
can attack it in a million different
ways c4 comes to mind
knight g4 black's got a very hard time
navigating here without his position
collapsing white is better for sure
so i hope that makes sense
oh really i'm glad to hear that so he
plays d4 we go knight c4
um now this pawn is hanging
and he goes bishop g4 which is good and
now
um the move rookie 4 i think is
quite nice occupying the second square
weakened by the move d4 we could have
also gone
queenie two intending to put a queen on
e4 i think that was also a possibility
but i saw here the possibility of
sacrificing the exchange
so i decided to go for this instead
um now the move queen d7 leads
essentially to
a loss you know five moves later he was
dead in the water
what could black have done instead well
the move i thought he would play as h5
in order to cement the bishop on g4 this
is technically an outpost and here
i was going to sacrifice an exchange
with rook takes g4 i haven't talked
about positional sacrifices yet that
isn't a pretty advanced concept
it's an advanced concept not because
it's hard to understand what it means to
sacrifice positionally it's quite easy
to understand
what that means and all that it really
means is
you sacrifice tactically when you
sacrifice for an attack or for checkmate
when you sacrifice in order to gain
squares for your pieces or compensation
that's
that's more you know that's more
positional in nature that has to do with
peace placement or
outposts or pawn structure all of that
falls under the umbrella of the
positional sacrifice
and most players including gm's find it
much harder
to go for positional sacrifices because
there's a greater risk
the compensation isn't quite as easy to
detect in most cases
so it could backfire very very easily
it's less concrete
sometimes it disappears here that is an
exception
the compensation is not just obvious but
completely overwhelming
where should the night go
beautiful square on h2 then g4
white's compensation first of all will
consist of a pawn second of all
the light squares are just amazing that
bishop's going to come out to me look at
these squares
all of the pieces are ideal in the long
run black's king is going to get caught
in a big attack so just because you
sacrifice positionally doesn't mean you
don't want to attack eventually
it just means the immediate compensatory
factors are positional
and perhaps the most common type of
exchange positional exchange sacrifice
is one to get either an outpost
for several of your pieces or one of
your pieces or
to institute a bind on one of the colors
of squares
you often sack in exchange to get a
light square bind in the center or an
outpost for a night as well as a bind
there's a lot of famous examples of that
that i could give petrosian was famous
for exchange sacrifices
like that and you can sort of see that
here
um so i hope this makes sense by the way
an outpost you know a square like this
which can't be assailed by pawns
um yeah so this is totally an absolutely
crushing
now sacrifice on h4 is nothing because
black doesn't have enough pieces in the
attack we can go knight takes g4
and conveniently defend f2
all right so i was hoping he would do
that
he also could have gone bishop h5
and then we probably would have brought
our queen to e1
in order to unpin and lay on the
pressure on the e5 pawn
all right so queen d7 and now knight
takes c5 is a very thematic tactic
takes takes attacking the queen he
should have taken
this uh this night and
it's it's not that simple here because
i i recognize that we have a problem if
we do this
black can go knight f6 and this rook
can't go back to e4 you have to go to g6
now black and try to trap the rook with
king f7 and i didn't quite like the look
of this
you might end up having to sacrifice the
exchange which is not the end of the
world but not ideal
so what i had come up with during the
game
was the move rook takes g4 and after
knight f6
i thought we would uh think on our feet
here but rook g6 seems
safer here but now there's queen f5
and amazingly again the rook is kind of
trapped here
h5 simply knight takes h5
so yeah i'm not quite sure bishop before
and i take c4
that's quite interesting um it may be
that i
that i underestimated this particular
way of
uh of engineering counter play
so i suppose one thing that you could do
is yeah this is you see these kinds of
things happen you just
realize that uh that um
that's him you know you kind of realize
that you missed some sort of crazy
tactical fluke at the end of the line
you could sacrifice on f6 and then take
on b7 white it's not going to be worse
here why there's two bonds for the
exchange technically white is the one up
material
then you can put the bishop on this
outpost white's better here white's
still much better
but um that's not necessarily what i had
intended
so in any case you know i make these
kinds of calculation errors and
why did i make this error because i
stopped calculating this is a classic
error of stopping too soon
and not realizing that that rook on g4
is in trouble
what if bishop f5 instead of queen d7
well you tell me can we engineer an
exchange sacrifice do we even have to
move the rook
what would be a very savvy move assuming
that black's going to take the rook on
e4
what piece do you want to bring into a
position
where it can get to e4 and occupy that
outpost
you have a very nice positional move
here if you want it
you can in fact sacrifice the exchange
in several different ways you can play
knight f to d2 yeah now there is the
direct sacrifice rook takes e5 that
gives you a pawn for the exchange
on the other hand it opens the e file
and i'm not sure that white is the one
who benefits from that
the fact that black has upon e5 is good
for us
because it gives this rook less
prospects not fd2
paves the way for the knight to come to
e4 this bishop could go to h3
look at these knights this queen of g4
it should be obvious
to everybody that white's compensation
once again is completely overwhelming
this isn't a matter of
white has full compensation white is
crushing here
if you turn on the computer i can almost
guarantee you
that it's going to be an advantage of
plus one or more for white despite being
down in exchange
because of these massive and permanent
weaknesses
okay so these exchange sacrifices are
not like
they're not crazy to understand why it
exchanges a lot of material but it's not
like just hacking a queen
all right so yeah i was never worried
about b5
it's plus two okay nice
um rfd8 knight takes c5
and uh no no black can't equalize black
is losing
black is losing white's compensation for
the exchange
is so vast that it literally it
overcompensates
by a very large margin for the exchange
you can't think of the compensation in
terms of material
right the compensation is less tangible
than just saying the compensation is
like worth two pawns if that makes sense
okay so again here knight takes f6 would
have been a pitfall to avoid
because no plus one is not a instead win
because the rook is hanging and the pawn
on c2 is hanging there was no need for
that we just take the pawn instead
drop the rook to e2 opening up an attack
on b7
okay b6 loses faster but uh
he should have gone bishop to d1 and
then we just drop our rook to e1 then
take b7
we're two pawns up totally dominating in
terms of our piece placement and so the
game is basically over
um the only other thing i wanted to
mention is
this one brook takes c2 he had rook ac8
if you remember let's say that you had
blundered into this
how should white play this in order to
get as much as possible in return for
the night
yeah so there's a temptation that i was
that i thought some of you would fall
into in 96
but remember that the bishop defends the
rook so this merely leads to a trade
which is good for black because he gets
a nice rook on c2
so buttmeister you found it the move is
b4
you want to defend the knight with the
pawn so that you can get
sorry so that you can at least get
another pawn for the piece you have two
extra pawns and a passer
which is going to get to c6 white is
completely winning here as well
and uh we decided to go bishop a there
was no need for that
and so up in exchange in two pawns the
game is simply over here
okay here in this position when bishop
and if i plays bishop d1
um oh here no but bishop d5
rook takes d5 i would have just dropped
the rook to e1
i'm glad to hear that but meister that's
awesome
why not 96 instead of bishop a a well
bishop a takes the rook
this is fine now 96 is fine but why over
complicate things like now
it's a headache to deal with all the
rooks that are hanging you know
maybe this is marginally better but we
just take the rokin
uh an easy way to understand this is
like black is going to take two of our
pieces and we're gonna take
the bishop we've already taken a rogue
so we're gonna be an exchange shop at
the end of it
that's all good um
what's the difference in a passer and a
weak pawn
well a pass spawn and a weak fun are
like on different planes
a passport could also be weak um
but not all weak pawns are passed then
i'll not all past once a week there's
just different concepts passpond is upon
that there's no
pawn obstructions on its way to
promotion
uh but the reason that the pawn on i
assume you met the pawn on c5
why is it not a weak pawn because when
you advance the spawn to c6
it is permanently protected by the
bishop black is no dark squared bishop
so black can essentially never mount
serious pressure on the pawn
i think that phrase sounds sophisticated
but it's actually
tautology and meaningless like most of
the things that i say
if you actually stop to think about it
but you see what i'm saying
but you got to be careful yeah past
pawns can be very scary looking and also
very weak
uh and and you should definitely ask
yourself that question
oh god there are essentially ice well no
there
you can be connected past ones
okay so after we did this
the rest was very obvious king of one i
won't really comment on it
any questions about the first part of
the game
i have one explanatory
segment to cement the concept of
positional exchange sacrifices before we
move on perhaps to one
more game i'm pretty tired that was a
long explanation okay um great let me
just show you
one other game segment very famous from
tigran petrossians
games petrosian is known for his
exchange sacrifices particularly in
uh very bad positions that's just what
he's famous for
uh one of the many things he's famous
for and one of his most famous exchange
sacrifices
and remember uh a lot of them
particularly defensive exchange
sacrifices they occur when you need to
institute a bind on let's say the light
squares
otherwise your opponent's going to crash
through so you hack an exchange
and then you somehow reroute your pieces
to establish a blockade
um so this is a very very good example
i'm about to show you of
petrossian doing that with uh with
success
all right and he he draw this is not
again that he wins in the end he draws
it
but it's a game in which he seems to be
in a great deal of trouble
so i quite like
this as a uh it's relatively simple to
understand
so he's playing roshewski who's
obviously not a
slouch was not a slouch himself
either uh and and so this is one of the
most famous tournaments of all time
zurich 1953.
bronstein wrote a super famous book
about it that i think is a little bit
overrated but
still is uh worth worth looking into
and petrosian is is black here
he's in time pressure as as always he's
they were always in time pressure and um
it may not seem like black is in any
kind of trouble at first
particularly because you may pay
attention to the fact that the bishop on
b2 is bad
but also look at this incredible pawn
chain
and if you look carefully white has just
played the move rook after e1
in the context of that move it becomes
easier to see what white is threading
what is white threatening here if it's
white to move
what does he do and this move just like
crashes through
right down the middle e6 this just looks
awful for black
black's pieces are sort of
discombobulated the knight has no
prospects
i mean this just is awful and it takes
like d5 and
black's getting blown off the board here
and rashevsky
undoubtedly was uh already sort of
you know it's always exciting to beat
someone like the trojan
but tigran finds uh one of his most
famous defensive ideas
to stop that and i'm quite impressed
that many of you
are already finding the idea i'll give
you guys a second
to think about it let me just make it a
little bit colder i'll be
right back
nice rookie six yeah so in this terrible
book
mastering positional chess i
i have this example
i have a chapter on uh on positional
sacrifices
and it's 63 pages long so that was a
choice i made which
which sort of is is rather unusual i
don't think that's that positional
sacrifice is talked about
that much impositional uh
books so that's part of the reason i
made such a long chapter on it because i
think it's very very important
even if you don't like sacrifice
positionally every game
it's still very instructive i think to
observe under what circumstances
positional sacrifices are warranted
um so i'm using it in the defense
chapter rookie six double exclam
a wonderful idea if white takes the rook
his position after f takes e6 followed
by 97 d5
will be miserable i mean look at this
regrouping
an incredible regrouping but also quite
easy to understand
his bishop on b2 will be a big pawn
black's pieces will be perfectly
coordinated
therefore roshewski had to find a way to
try to stop 9795
he like petrosian never panicked and
said he searched for ways to activate
the b2 bishop
a bishop on a3 would not only stop
knight e7 but also control the f8 square
therefore a4 the roshevsky finds an
interesting move
um but
uh you know this doesn't this isn't that
strong and petrosian finds
an even stronger response now
roshevsky's idea
is if he had gone before which is super
tempting
rashford spotted a really cool idea this
pawn on c4
becomes very loose so what little
small tactical idea does does white have
here
what comes to mind
now roxy1 is too passive it's d5
yeah and what happens here is that the
position
opens up and when the position opens up
the power of a blockade
greatly reduces that should just that
should be evident and in particular the
exchange sacrifice
is unwarranted because the files are
opened all the stuff is happening
and um you know white's rooks are going
to be
monsters with so many files open so
petrossian just ignores him it goes 97
and 95
anyway and he manages to keep the
position relatively closed
by preserving uh this pawn chain b5 c4
rook f3 bishop d3 rushevsky sensing that
he's about to be worse he sacrifices the
exchange back
and he wins upon the patron with a
monster knight on d5
uh is very very comfortable the game
ended in a draw in in 10 more moves
which are which are far less interesting
but basically petrossian has fully
equalized
uh so you know that's a
classic example of uh
of of the sort of exchange sacrifice
this is white fc4 if c4
then you go knight b6 then black's going
to take on e4 i don't want to be labor
the point
i have one more really good example
of of an exchange sacrifice less famous
exchange sacrifice
by petrosian to really hammer home the
theme we won't spend a long time on it i
promise i will
be relatively swift and then we will
move on i think it's
but you know it does show you how
pieces really do have relative value and
it all depends on the concrete factors
uh
you know whether whether something like
an exchange sacrifice would work
this is 1983 both polygayefsky and
petrosian
were in this was one year before
petrossian's uh untimely death
uh very tragic of course in his 50s
of cancer um but he was good up until
basically his last days
so yeah petrosian passed away very young
so poligayevsky was was one of the
strongest soviet players
and he was 26 25 which was very high
rating at the time
so um so what to do in this position
well you guys
i've already set it up for you so the
move itself should be very intuitive
the reasoning behind it is more
interesting but
what's the move do the honors
so the way that i describe it is like
this
i'll read you my comment from mastering
positional chess because i'm too lazy to
explain it
again at first sight it may seem that
the position is approximately equal
white has the bishop pair but black has
the c5 square for his knight
protrusion asked himself the question if
i could take any white piece off the
board what would it be
the ant well oh the queen the answer is
the e3 bishop
the bishop holds white's position
together defends c5
and controls many important squares
petrosian's next move shows immense
positional understanding
he correctly asserts that the bishop is
in this case more important than the e8
rook
thus takes e3 double exclaim the
elimination of the bishop is not the
only reason petrosian made this move
after f takes e3 this pawn will be
extremely weak and subject to attack
also white species will become
completely uncoordinated the b4 rook
will be awkwardly placed
of course black isn't winning but from a
practical point of view it's very hard
to play white on the situation
so knight c5 i mean look how easy
black's plays the dark square control is
unbelievable the rook comes into e8
and this is evidenced by the fact that
immediately blunders he can try to hold
his position together petrossian piles
up on the pawn
but poliwski loses his mind with rook b6
which is an interesting idea he wanted
the trojan to take and then he would i
think have sacrificed the exchange
back what did he miss this is classic
tunnel vision
of course he was already on the verge of
panic knight a4
and he resigned of course after queen
before you take the rook
and then you win the other exchange and
it's very ironic that black is the one
who's going to end up in exchange
at the end of everything so he wins both
of white's exchanges
all right um so that's another
relatively simple sacrifice
but a very beautiful one nonetheless
classic classic game petrosian had
probably seven or eight of these kinds
of sacrifices
okay um oh skye is queen c5
oh why is queen c5 not good sorry i
missed your question
so queen c5 is
not as good because the rook can drop to
b3
and you're uh stealing the c5 score from
the night also rook takes b7 is an
additional option because again remember
when you sacrifice the exchange you want
to keep files as closed as possible when
files become open
the rooks become stronger and you start
regretting and this rook on b7 is
obviously very strong
but even forget the b7 pawn more
importantly the c5 square belongs to the
knight
you could also make a case for putting
the knight on e5 but then it would block
the bishop
you want to find the squares where every
piece does its own thing and doesn't
block any other pieces
and this is the most natural square for
the knight i i hope that makes sense
also
the queen and the rook then have holmes
on e7 and ea
if you put the knight on e5 not only
does it block the bishop it blocks
a rook that would come to e8 sorry to
belabor the point but i think it's a
good question